un bonjour alexis merci d'être avec nous
à nouveau en ce lundi pour décrypter ce
second tour des élections régionales et
départementales quelle leçon pour ce
deuxième tour selon vous combien déjà
l'abstention qui restent à un niveau
historique pour ce deuxième tour à peu
près pareil que le premier tour à ça un
peu un léger sursaut mais rien comparé
aux appels au vote de toute la semaine à
la fois des appareils de parti mais
aussi du gouvernement essayant de
booster un peu ces élections régionales
donc clairement les français qui boudent
les urnes qui refusent de voter soit
parce que l'offre politique ne leur
ressemblent pas soit parce qu'ils n'ont
pas non plus compris l'enjeu de ce
scrutin local c'est assez drôle
d'ailleurs de voir que dans notre pays
finalement nous avons un taux
d'abstention aussi élevés et tant d'élus
puis le plus de 700 mille élus 520000
locaux c'est presque un élu pour 100
habitants donc c'est inédit en europe on
a beaucoup d'élus en france mais très
peu de votants et c'est vrai que la
leçon c'est quasiment cette amende est
comment ça fonctionne et c'est vrai que
du coup la victoire de ceux qui ont
gagné
et quand même gâché par cette abstention
est la vraie question c'est est-ce que
aujourd'hui le personnel politique est
capable de se remettre en question sur
ce désamour sur cette rupture profonde
entre un pays qui ne veut plus et puis
des politiques qui sont là à faire de la
politique politicienne a compté les voix
les sièges et voir comment ils peuvent
continuer car un cas leurs carrières
séparées des réalités finalement de
français qui se détournent des urnes et
c'est ça vraiment là la grande leçon
c'est à savoir il faudrait peut-être
pousser plus loin la réflexion que à oui
mais il y avait le coc vide les gens
sortaient ou bien il y avait des
problèmes de distribution des des outils
de propagande pour le vote je crois que
ça va au delà c'est peut-être un système
qui est à revoir
quelles conséquences alors pour le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche qui eux sont les grands
perdants de ce scrutin alors qu'on
annonce un ulm entre les deux camps la
présidentielle et alors c'est vrai que
pour pour
la république en marche et leur
assemblée nationale c'est une énorme
défaite
puisqu'on attendait pas du tout ce type
de de résultats
alors à la république en marche
peut-être un peu plus le président
emmanuel macron avait tenté de minimiser
déjà lors du premier tour faisant comme
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'élection il fait
la même chose aujourd'hui puisque il a
dit qu'il n'y aurait pas vraiment de
remaniement ministériel ni de leçons
national de ce scrutin local et
aujourd'hui on va retrouver emmanuel
macron dans le nord avec xavier bertrand
pour inaugurer une usine chinoise de
batterie donc c est certes des emplois
mais tout de même comment les deux vont
se comporter c'est à voir et puis il
reçoit ensuite des patrons
internationaux à versailles pour le
sommet choose france où il est question
bien sûr d'investissement dans notre
pays donc on pourra bien que l'idée pour
ronald mac ronces et de minimiser un
maximum cette défaite faisant comme si
ces élections n'avait aucun impact sur
la suite
pour marine le pen c'est un peu plus
compliqué elle avait critiqué ses
électeurs au soir du premier jour de
vote du premier tour
disons qu'il ne s'était pas à mobiliser
suffisamment elle était plutôt fâché et
puis hier dimanche soir elle est revenue
sur ses déclarations en félicitant les
électeurs du fn qui se sont déplacés et
qui ont fait un choix lucide disent
elles pour elle aussi c'est compliqué
aucune région alors que les sondages la
donnaient peu potentiel grande vainqueur
avec deux régions que le rn aurait pu
enfin gagner mais on se rend compte
qu'il ya un plafond de verre qui
s'appelle encore le front républicain
c'est à dire que de nombreux partis se
coalisent s'allient contre leur
assemblée nationale qui fait quand même
seuls des scores assez assez haut
comparé à ces partis qui sont obligés
d'être plusieurs contres contre le parti
de marine le pen
mais on voit bien que suite à la défaite
notamment de thierry mariani et en paca
qui était attendu il va y avoir sans
doute des réflexions stratégiques au
sein de l'appareil du rassemble
nationale notamment comment rassembler
davantage d'électeurs comment aussi
préparer une présidentielle avec des
élections intermédiaires qui ne sont pas
vraiment en faveur du rassemblement
national
on va continuer votre édito alexis poule
a on va écouter justement et thierry
mariani et renaud muselier en paca vous
des conventions les alpins et azuréens
vous avez fait un choix fondateurs et
décisif vous avez été scrutés décortiqué
analysé depuis plusieurs mois comme le
futur laboratoire du
nationale on nous promettait un destin
de cobaye nous avons opté pour un destin
de région libre nous avons refusé la
fatalité d'une région gouvernée par
l'extrême droite
cette décision nous l'avons prise en
conscience au delà des clivages
politiques
nous avons pris notre destin en main
nous avons pris notre destin en mains en
dehors des appareils politiques
c'est avec une grande tristesse que je
dois constater ce soir notre défaite
le changement que tant attendu n'aura
pas lieu
le système coalisés l'emporter au terme
d'une campagne qui n'honore pas nos
adversaires
voilà pour la région paca alexis à à
droite il ya donc trois candidatures à
venir ou xavier bertrand est il la seule
alternative alors xavier bertrand c'est
celui qui est parti le plus tôt un qui a
annoncé très tôt qu'il serait candidat à
l'élection présidentielle est donc pour
lui cette victoire elle est d'autant
plus importante parce qu'elle lui permet
de continuer d'expliquer aussi en disant
qu'il ne s'est jamais caché que donc
s'il quitte ses fonctions à la région il
avait prévu en amont et ça lui a permis
tout de même de gagner et de gagner
contre le rassemblement national qui
était un de ses objectifs mais il ya
aussi d'autres grands gagnants notamment
laurent wauquiez en auvergne qui a fait
un score plus long que bien à lui
bertrand et qui a des idées remis leur
assemblée nationale plus bas qui reste
encore très discret laurent wauquiez
mais qui pourrait dans l'est dans les
semaines qui viennent
commencé aussi à être plus vocal sur ses
ambitions pour 2022 est évidemment
valérie pécresse qui concerne la région
ile de france et qui là aussi pour être
une candidate pour les républicains
sachant qu'elle a voulu avoir un
discours rassembleur également en
expliquant qu'elle était aussi capable
de
de se lancer dans une élection
présidentielle reste à savoir comment
départager les ténors de la droite
puisque la plupart ne sont pas vraiment
pour une primaire même si la primaire
est dans les statuts des parties du
parti républicain donc
reste à voir comment tout cela se ferait
aujourd'hui c'est xavier bertrand un qui
se rêve en candidat idéal même si lui a
fait une scission avec les républicains
il ya déjà quelques années qui pourrait
handicaper sa candidature compte tenu
des autres candidats qui eux restent
ancrées au sein de leurs partis
historiques et pour emmanuel macron
évidemment est-ce qu'il faut envisager
un changement de stratégie selon vous
alors pour les mâles mâcon je crois que
sa stratégie depuis le début c'est le
déni c'est à dire faire comme si le pays
n'existait pas de faire comme si les
élections intermédiaires n'existait pas
et donc continuer dans une
histoire qu'il écrit lui-même un tempo
qui le veut donner lui-même le maître
des horloges qui est bien du mal avec la
crise sanitaire mais aussi avec la crise
des gilet jaune et qui continue comme si
de rien n'était la preuve aujourd'hui
avec cette visite à douai ensuite le
seul la rencontre à versailles avec les
patrons internationaux pour continuer de
faire ce qu'il fait c'est à dire vendre
à la découpe le pays et puis continuer
de dire qu'il est le seul rempart aux
racines nationales
ça parle ça paraît très faible en
réalité il ya deux stratégies à la fois
comment la république en marche va gérer
la suite on sent bien qu'il y à quelques
tensions au sein du mouvement avec
notamment la tête de stanislas guérini
qui qui serait mise à prix 1 puisque la
gestion est assez calamiteuse donc un
changement
l'idée aussi d'une dissolution de la
république en marche qui changerait de
nom qui s'intégrerait dans une plate
forme plus large une maison commune avec
les partis du centre a eu des modems et
d'autres pour permettre une nouvelle
plateforme à emmanuel macron mais pour
lui le cap est clair continuer sa
déambulation dans le pays cette mise en
scène du président et puis le discours
du 14 juillet qu'ils espèrent
refondateurs avec peut-être maintenant
on entend l'idée de réunir le parlement
en assemblée à versailles sans doute
pour annoncer les réformes de fin du
quinquennat ou la suite des opérations
avec en tête bien sûr gardé toutes les
chances d'une possible réélection en
2022 même si aujourd'hui on voit bien
que son parti ne s'est pas ancrée nine
dans lors des municipales ni lors des
régionales et reste un parti parisien a
cédé connectés finalement du pays et
malgré la présence de ministres sur les
listes ils sont tous je le rappelle à
arriver dernier à 7 % au niveau national
donc pour la république en marche
merci beaucoup alexis poulain pour ce
décryptage après cette élection
régionale et les élections
départementales on n'a pas parlé des
communistes inclus on parle perdu le val
de marne c'est là la grande surprise on
y reviendra
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour votre
intervention dans la matinale verte et
france